Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
In the last video,
we covered the history of Ireland from its early beginnings and left off with
the rule of Henry the aids,
which was a crucial time period for Ireland.
As the war of the roses had ended with Henry's father,
Protestantism started being introduced to Ireland and Henry made himself king of
Ireland rather than just lord of Ireland.
And then died in 1547 Henry was succeeded by his son who became Edward the sixth
Edward was a son for whom Henry had wished throughout his reign and the
Protestant air that the English were glad to see.
He lived to succeed his father,
but unfortunately he was sickly throughout his life.
Edward died in 1553 from an unknown cause,
likely tuberculosis or another disease affecting the lungs.
Though as with most deaths of historical figures,
some people speculate he was poisoned.
This created an interesting turn of events for not only England,
but Ireland as well.
During Edwards rain.
He and his administration had begun to feel as though bringing Ireland to
English rule required brute force.
The surrender and regret policy of Henry failed almost immediately as the Gaelic
Laura had agreed to it to get to king off their backs,
but then went back to really in their own lands in their own way and found the
government in Dublin too weak to do anything about it.
Though attempts were made to prevent her ascension following the death of
Edward,
his older sister Mary became queen of England.
Mary,
unlike her father and younger brother,
was firmly Catholic and would try to drag England from Protestantism back to
Catholicism in England.
Her methods of doing this would earn her the name Bloody Mary,
but in Ireland the Irish were fairly content with this.
Catholicism was not disappearing in Ireland and the English had often lack the
power to change that.
The Irish were glad to see Mary on the throne,
but nevertheless they weren't sure about the future and still felt a stronger
loyalty to their own people and to the pope and the church,
which in their eyes at this time kind of came before the English monarch.
Perhaps they were justified in doing so.
Mary,
the Catholic was still an English woman and made efforts to control Ireland
largely through the use of plantations.
A tactic which would change the face of Ireland forever plantations were
essentially forms of colonizing Ireland with loyal Englishman.
Queen Mary's main efforts were in the modern day Offley and leash called the
plantation of the Kings County and Queens County.
These areas were specifically chosen to displace rebellious Irishman,
the o'conners and a Morris.
In 1566 the local Irish weren't exactly content with this and pursued warfare
against the English.
Naturally the English had a hard time attracting settlers to such an area.
I'm sure you can imagine that if you were a well off Englishman or Englishwoman,
you wouldn't want to up root in an already unstable time to go live in a war
zone.
And for all and purposes.
These plantations essentially became military fortifications.
In November of 1558 Mary died despite attempts to prevent it.
Her sister Elizabeth was Exceder once again,
England was to change religions as her sister was a protestant and wished to
continue the work of her father.
Securing Ireland was now once more in modern terms,
a matter of national security for the Protestant English,
hoping to prevent the island from allying with the Spanish or French,
and being used as a base from which a Catholic invasion could come justifying
further the very costly efforts to subdue the island.
This fear was not quite so unrealistic and in fact,
in Elizabeth's first years as ruler,
she was faced with this issue and Ulster,
the Earl of Tyrone Shane O'Neill acted increasingly troublesome.
He had taken the rule of Tyrone illegally in the eyes of the English as his
father had declared his first born son,
his successor,
but in accordance with Gaelic Breton law,
Shane took a position for himself and to feed it English attempts to stop him
though an enemy of England and an ally of the Scottish McDonald clan,
which was settling in interim at the time,
who were photos of the English.
Elizabeth was forced to negotiate.
She offered to allow shame to keep his role so long as he accepted English law
and submitted to the Lord Deputy of Ireland,
the Earl of Sussex,
but he refused.
And in 1561 Shane defeated the English again at the battle of red seconds.
Within his reign,
he would become the enemy of other Irish Lords,
the McDonald's of Scotland and the English surrounded by enemies.
He went so far as to invite the French into the fight and even offered to become
a subject of the French king.
Consequently,
he was heavily pursued by the English under Sir Henry Sydney,
but he was beheaded by the antrum Scott's before they could reach them.
In 1567 Shane's head was taken to Dublin where it rested on a pike on the castle
walls.
Elizabeth continued to pursue a military campaign against Ireland and those
Shane O'Neill was defeated.
The own Niels and Ulster in general were and would continue to be a problem for
the English Elizabeth's forces swept through Ireland subduing much of the island
removing moving Catholicism where ever they sought often violently and reforming
the island to be truly English,
not Anglo,
Irish or worse Gaelic Irish.
Yet olster remained the most defined.
Shane successor Turla knock,
gathered together an Irish and Scottish forced to stand against the English
invaders at the same time,
rebellions and conflict and months there were sprouting up in response to
Elizabeth's attempts at plantation there.
These plantation attempts would also be disastrous as the rebellions continued
for decades with the slaughtering of the innocent scorched earth tactics,
guerrilla warfare,
mercilessness against foes and foreign intervention from Spain and the pope by
the 1590s one third of monsters.
Population had died from the conflict,
starvation and sickness in olster conflict came again under a ruler whom the
English had thought to be loyal to the crown hew own Neil.
He O'neil had formed an alliance of Auster chieftains and asked for assistance
from Spain and then moved against England,
sparking an event in April of 1593 which would come to be known as a nine years
of war.
The English brought together an army of 27,000 men to deal with this threat,
the largest forest to invade Ireland.
Up to that point ever,
despite this intimidating force,
the Irish were seeing victory and by 1596 we're receiving supplies and later
soldiers from the Spanish,
the Spanish armada had been defeated by the English a decade earlier and they
were eager to get back at them and deal a blow to them and a two countries
continuous struggle.
Essentially all of Ireland outside the pail wasn't open rebellion and in league
with the Catholic Spanish.
The nine years war was more than just a thorn in the side of England winning.
It was now a matter of securing England itself at the siege of Kinsale from 1601
the 1602 at tides turned on the Irish.
Their defeat at the hands of Charles Blount,
the Earl of mountain joy would cause the Spanish to pull out from their
intervention and the rebellion in Ireland to fade on March 30th,
1603 he will,
Neil surrendered conflict within then slowly start to come to a close in April
though Elizabeth had died a week prior.
On March 24th she had finally achieved what no other English ruler had rural of
the entire island of Ireland.
It came at great costs.
However,
England wasn't debt.
By around 400,000 pounds,
at least a hundred thousand people died in this conflict,
including 30,000 English soldiers,
largely from famine and disease.
Many of the earls left Ireland not long after an event known as the flight of
the Earl's to stay in Catholic Europe and look for military backing to return to
Ireland and reclaim it.
Fun side fact provided my family tree is accurate.
One of my great grandfathers,
Richard Boyle,
was actually involved in these events.
Eventually becoming the Earl of Cork and the father of Robert Boyle,
making him my great uncle.
After having worked with Queen Elizabeth and all of that,
he comes into the Labia.
Let Line my last name through my paternal grandfather's great grandmother.
Not that I'd take England site in this.
I really take sides on this channel.
Just thought,
uh,
you know,
throw that in there.
Anyway,
now we can go around the class and you all can tell me a fun fact about
yourself.
Elizabeth was succeeded by her cousin James,
who is James the first of England and Ireland and James is sixth of Scotland.
Scotland was held in a personal union,
was England and Ireland,
but existed as its own country with its own laws.
Nevertheless,
the three countries along with of course Wales,
which was at this under England,
but not to be forgotten,
we're all United under one monarch.
For the first time in history,
James would continue much of the work of his tutor,
predecessors,
namely plantations and spreading Protestantism in Ireland.
Throughout his kingdom.
Catholic priests were banished and the tendance at Protestant religious services
were compulsory.
Though as usual,
these laws had much less effect in Ireland,
which still remained Catholic.
Admittedly,
however,
James lightened up on Irish Catholics more than his predecessors avoiding
potential conflict.
James,
his lasting legacy in Ireland would be continuing the plantations most
significantly in Ulster.
As we've discussed,
attempts at plantation and Ireland prior to this were a significant failures.
This time James focused on olster the land,
which was historically difficult for the English or control and an area where
the government had an opportunity to seize land with less commotion.
As much of the land was owned by the rebellious earls who had left and the
flight of the Earl's by 1610 after Len and population surveys were undertaken
and maps were created,
the process of plantation had begun,
many who were given land where the servitors soldiers who had served the queen
loyally during the nine years war and men who could for the more defend the
territory if need be.
Many others came from England and especially Scotland,
where Presbyterian Scots became the Ulster Scotts.
There was naturally great emphasis on these settlers being Protestant.
If they were Catholics,
it would defeat the purpose after all,
however many native Irish regretted lands as well.
In exchange for loyalty to the crown,
though their taxes were higher.
The process of plantation and Ulster continued with John's successor,
Charles the first and by 1641 the population of planter is in Ireland,
reached about a hundred thousand which was one 10th of Ireland's population at
the time.
A huge wave of people in a short time,
but regardless and the rest of Ireland,
Catholic Irish still controlled three fourths of the country.
Families such as the Johnston's,
Graham's Armstrong's Montgomery's,
Hamilton's Gibbons,
et cetera.
We're active in this plantation.
Naturally,
the English replacing emphasis on their loyal and Protestant planters over the
Anglo Irish nor refer to as the old English,
the descendants of the Normans,
if you recall,
and of course the Gaelic Irish James had held things together fairly well,
but Charles the first was a lot less successful of a monarch in many ways as we
will see and upset the Irish,
the old English,
and even the planters.
Furthermore,
he was not alone in this.
His Lord Deputy of Ireland,
Thomas Wentworth,
the Earl of Strafford,
played a big role to Charles had major enemies in England and Scotland as well.
Early on in his reign,
he became involved in the 30 years war,
a conflict in Europe to find by religious differences,
but also political.
Throughout his reign,
Charles would lose the support of parliament and be in constant conflict with
them,
never truly seeing eye to eye.
When Charles had attended a force Anglican religious practices on the
Presbyterian Scottish,
it led to the bishop's war.
When the covenant of Scotland rebelled,
parliament refuse to give Charles to funds to fight his fellow Protestants and
things began to truly start heating up and bring the bishop's war would be the
prelude to the English civil war,
which was a conflict belonging to a much larger series of complex known as the
wars of the three kingdoms.
England was about to spend the rest of the century with the power and England
being bounced around various factions.
And as with other incidents in English history,
like the war of the roses,
this was going to affect Ireland's significantly as well.
In Ireland,
the government in Dublin felt much the same way as the parliament of England and
when the Lord Deputy of Ireland was raising an army to assist Charles,
they executed him.
People in England began to choose sides in a civil war,
which was now inevitable.
Those loyal to the King English Catholics,
the nobility and the Welsh in Cornish came together as the royalist.
Under Charles,
the Protestants,
Scottish and common folk tended to support the parliamentarians on rather
rebellious parliament.
In Ireland,
a similar divide was taking shape,
the olster planters and the government and the Pale lean towards supporting the
parliamentarians.
Whereas the Irish Catholics who saw Charles as a more lenient king,
especially compared to the more devout the Protestant parliamentarians and
hostile Protestant Scottish,
we threatened them,
saw Charles as the better option.
Both sides were ultimately motivated by fear.
The Irish feared a stark,
the Protestant government who would wage war on their beliefs and their country,
the English and Scottish fear to king who ruled without parliament.
And could even restore Catholicism,
the nation with the help of an Irish army.
This fear will become brutal.
Anger.
Rebellion in Ireland erupted in October of 1641 Catholic Irish gentry such as
feel I'm O'neil Rory,
or more Donald McCarthy and Connor McGuire.
Plan too surprising leash and take Dublin Castle and parts of Ulster,
and then issued a man's for the rights of Catholics to be recognized.
They intended to do this with little bloodshed and figured that when they
control these areas,
the Irish Catholic majority was support them on.
Fortunately for them,
a Protestant spy,
oh and O'Connelly discover the plot and the element of surprise was gone.
Dublin castle was not taken,
but areas of Ulster were captured.
They claim to be acting in the name of the king,
but this was almost certainly not the case.
And his suppose it instructions were forgeries,
but it helps give the parliamentarians the incentive to move against the king.
Anyway,
the English reacted by sending an army into Ireland,
fearing the worst.
The brutality of these soldiers only exacerbated things and caused more of the
Irish to rise up in rebellion.
And as the country's situation flamed,
things became bloodier and Ulster a metaphor,
harvest and economic decline.
The local peasants rose up in anger and fear against the olds.
There's settlers killing many innocent families.
The leaders of the rebellion tried to stop them,
but they were unable to prevent a swarm of peasants that they had inadvertently
unleashed.
Estimates.
Put the total number of all sir planters at 4,000 killed with around 10 to
12,000 more killed by related famine and disease.
The English for propaganda reasons slightly exaggerated this number to 200,000
imagine taking something like the nine 11 attacks and reporting instead that the
entire state of New York was a vaporized by nuclear weapons based on a wheel
incident,
but exaggerate it to an extreme degree is uncertain whether or not there were
even 200,000 officer planters in total.
But this goes to show a,
how crucial the English felt getting the population on their side was and B,
how little people really knew because of how poorly information traveled in the
17th century makes it really appreciate this whole Internet thing.
Charles sent forces to Ireland who were purportedly there to put down the
rebellion,
but in truth ended up working with the Irish rebels in 1642 the English civil
war had truly begun.
As the parliamentarian is declared their intention to punish all Catholics for
the rebellion of the prior year.
Nearly all Ireland rose up in revolt.
Later that year.
In May,
the Irish gentry met at Kilkenny and established central leadership under the
Confederation of Ireland.
This was not really an independence movement,
but it was absolutely a movement against the English to force them to recognize
the rights of Catholics.
The pope sent an envoy partially in support of the rebellion,
but also to ensure a focus on Catholicism not merely lend or political rights.
By 1649 the English and Scottish and captured King Charles and beheaded him,
the English civil war had for now and one with a parliamentarian victory.
And England came one of the rule of their new government with a man named Oliver
Cromwell and control of the new model army,
one of the most powerful armed forces in the world at a time with England secure
chrom wellness plan to move into Ireland where he would become one of the most
hated figures in Irish history.
He arrived in Ireland in August of that year,
focusing on taking and securing olster and the major cities.
By winter,
much of the island was under his rule.
By 1652 Ireland had been subdued Cromwell sought not only to subjugate the
Irish,
but eradicate Catholicism.
During the period of 1641 1652 Ireland's population was cut almost in half by
disease,
famine,
and brutal unrestrained killing and the majority of the dead were Catholics.
Soldiers and civilians alike were killed and enslaved and shipped off to work
and the Caribbean,
including Catholic priests who were specific target as there were often bounties
placed on them.
Many were clubbed to death to save bullets.
Some were lucky and fled to Spain or France.
Cranwell began confiscating land from the Irish betting.
Many of the former rebellious cath land owners to,
as I said,
the Caribbean as slaves or to desolate regions and Conoco.
The land was then returned to Protestant lords and soldiers who are owed wages.
Thus,
the land was ruled in the majority by Protestants about 10,000 Protestant
settled throughout Ireland and lands given to them as payment for the services.
Soldiers were required to keep their weapons and serve as a militia in England.
Cromwell was essentially acting as a king and all but name,
but he did not live to rule for long dying and 1658 England would return to the
rural of a monarchy as Charles a second.
Charles at first son claim the throne.
Charles a second would make the wise move of pardoning many of those who had
acted against his father,
including in Ireland,
but he would not allow all the changes to remain.
He moved to return land.
We small percentage of the Catholic population in Ireland who could prove that
they were not a part of the rebellion.
It was not a huge increase going from only about 10 to now,
20% of the land being owned by Catholics,
but it's slightly ease,
the still very strong tensions and a grave times Arland was facing the tables
flipped yet again in England as Charles is second names a catholic heir to the
throne who would become James is second in 1685 this,
as you might expect,
caused a great deal of commotion and England having a Catholic monarch
threatened Protestants in England and their hold and Ireland especially as James
had named a Catholic Lord Deputy of Ireland.
The commotion settled down when he named his daughter Mary,
who was married to William of Orange Dot holder the Netherlands is air,
both of whom are Protestant.
The English breathed a sigh of relief and then he changed his mind.
He named his Catholic son to be his there and parliament rose up against them.
The challenge,
the monarchy,
once again,
in an event known as the Glorious Revolution,
William was made king along with his co monarch wife,
Mary James Flood to Ireland,
where he knew the Catholic population,
what support him in Ireland.
This led to the William might wars,
which was both a war for the throne of England,
but also an Irish attempt at rebellion and revenge against the Protestant elite
with a Catholic English king making a grab for the throne.
This was their chance,
James,
with backing from King Louis,
the 14th of France attempted to secure control of Ireland,
but by 1691 limerick had been taken and he recognized his defeat was inevitable.
He abandoned his forces fleeing France,
earning him.
The name Shamus on Haka,
Shamus being the Irish equivalent word for James Schamus,
James,
Sean,
John,
etc. And on a Haka being a title that you don't really want as a ruler,
the prewar order returned.
The Protestant elite assumed command of Ireland.
Catholics were borrowed from a number of physicians.
Observance of Catholicism was banned and the large number of rebels were
deported.
The friends in an event known as the flight of the wild geese.
It is from this time that the Protestant Irish associate themselves with the
Color Orange and association,
which lasts to this day,
and the victory of this war is still celebrated by the Protestant Irish as well.
The Protestants crackdown on Irish Catholics again,
who had been troublesome throughout the 17th century.
The distinction between a Gaelic Irish and the Norman Irish disappeared.
Old penal laws were reintroduced alongside new ones.
Catholic land ownership fell significantly.
Catholics could not vote or hold public office.
They could not run schools.
They could not enter legal professions and they could not bear arms or hold
higher ranks in the army.
However,
it was not illegal,
per se to be a catholic.
The English at this point,
we're more concerned with controlling the Catholics rather than converting
droves of them,
and the Catholicism was heavily regulated and looked down upon,
but not exactly illegal.
Nevertheless,
Catholicism held on strongly in Ireland.
At the start of the 18th century,
75% of the country was still Catholic being ruled by less than the top 25% as
now Presbyterian officer.
Scots weren't on the same level as Anglican Irish either.
The English still how remake conversion and enticing and easy option publicly
denounced Catholicism convert to the Protestant faith and your rights were
returned.
Some went along with this,
nine did not.
In 1707 under Queen Anne,
the successor of the joint monarchs,
King William,
the third and married a second.
The acts of union merged the kingdoms of England and Scotland into the United
Kingdom of Great Britain.
Ireland was no longer just a possession of England.
It was now a part of the British empire,
which would spend the next two centuries becoming the largest empire in world
history
compared to the 17th century when blood was spilled across the whole island of
Ireland and rebellions,
religious conflicts and civil wars.
The early half of the 18th century was a less violent time for Ireland,
sometimes referred to as the long peace love.
Of course.
That is not to say that the Irish,
namely the Catholic majority,
we're content with things or that it was a prosperous age for the country.
There was considerable economic,
technological,
social and architectural development in this time period.
Famous figures like Jonathan Swift of Dublin,
known for his work such as Gulliver's travels and Edmund Burke.
I'm Dublin,
a statesman and philosopher.
We're born this time though,
as you might expect from what we've covered so far.
Much of this progress and enlightenment was unique to the cities and the
plantations.
Ireland outside of his land was a rural place dependent on subsistence farming.
Many of the landowners were English men who weren't frequent residents have
their own land.
In Ireland,
though firmly under English,
Protestant,
Rural Ireland was very much also a place where two distinct cultures existed
parallel to each other.
In 1740 a devastating famine had Ireland caused by extreme,
unusual cold.
Around 400,000 people would die that winter and another 150,000 would emigrate
to brings colonies.
The situation was exacerbated by a serious drought the following spring.
Many of those afflicted worthy,
impoverished city dwellers.
The 400,000 dead and the 150,000 who would leave equaled about 30% of Arlene's
population.
At the time,
Ireland had retained its religion,
but it was now in a 1750s beginning to lose another feature of its identity,
its language.
It was in the 18th century that bilingualism became more and more important to
the Irish people as knowing English allowed them to interact with the more
prosperous English society.
The decline of the Irish language truly took off in the 19th century as many
Irish would leave for other parts of the British empire or its successor states
like the u s and Canada who spoke English,
English for become so common that today many outside Ireland and the United
Kingdom are often not aware that a separate language apart from English exists
in Ireland.
I can personally say that this is the case in the United States where many
people are surprised to learn that the Irish have their own language,
but indeed,
until the 19th century Irish was the majority language of the country.
Irish is a Celtic language distinct from dramatic languages like English and
German and the romance languages like French,
Spanish,
and Italian.
It is not left many marks on English despite its proximity.
The many names like Sean Shamus,
Coleen,
which comes from Colleen,
the word for girl,
Brian,
popular from of course Brian Burrow and Brendan main prints are popular these
days.
These spelling and pronunciation are very foreign to English speakers as well as
the structure of the language itself.
The phrase on will,
a gala,
Goget meaning do you speak Irish is technically literally translated.
Is There Irish at you?
There is also no exact word for yes or no.
A feature shared with other languages like Latin finish and other closely
related languages like Scottish Gaelic and Menkes.
People respond with the affirmative or negative of the verb,
the political atmosphere of our limb.
Again,
the change in the sixties and seventies a major cause of such change was the
American war of independence.
The British desperate for troops lifted many bands on Irish Catholic in the
military,
in shipped many Irishmen to fight on the side of Britain and the war.
Many Irish Protestants,
however,
actually favored the American side of the war as they felt as well that they
should be governing Arland on their own with less interference from London on
the colonial side.
Many olster Scots Irish had immigrated to America and played an important role
in the war of independence during this time to secure a Catholic loyalties to
crown the English.
Granted Len owning Catholics the right to vote.
By 1783 many Irishmen took part in a successful rebellion against England,
though on another continent during the American war of independence,
the Irish parliament in a period of its history known as Gretchen's parliament.
After the very vocal Henry gratin began making similar requests from the British
government.
The Irish were less revolutionary and didn't seek to cut ties with Britain as
America eventually decided to do,
but the British weren't prepared to handle yet another conflict.
Say what you will about how the American Revolution was handled when it came to
Ireland.
The British showed the world that they had learned their lesson.
In 1782 the British allowed the Irish parliament more self rule over their
country.
This was hardly a real concession.
Though the control of Ireland still remained in London.
These concessions would not halt feelings of nationalism and new political
thinking,
which had been spreading across the western world.
In 1789 the French people revolted against their monarchy over throwing it and
declaring their nation to be a republic.
This movement would greatly inspire the Irish,
especially as they had seen that decade that their parliament was almost as an
effective as ever.
In 1791 in Belfast,
Northern Ireland,
a group of Protestants formed the Society of the United Irishmen led by a 28
year old man named Thea Wolfe tone.
The United Irishmen took a unique perspective to the concept of Irish
independence,
largely inspired by the French.
One of the main new ideas was an alliance between Protestant and Catholic,
a union of mutual Irishness and disdain of the crown in which Irish Catholic and
Protestant work together in one nation to achieve independence.
Wolfe tone began seeking allies at home and abroad.
He would form an alliance with a group of Catholic Middleclass Irishman known as
it offenders,
led by Matthew Murdoch.
Actually Murdoch has a different group of defenders,
although he is Irish Catholic,
so I was on the right track more threateningly the Irish sought the aid of the
French Wolfe tone traveled to France to meet with the revolutionary government.
When Wolfe tone met with this government,
he painted a slightly inaccurate picture of his nation.
He told them that all of Ireland favorite France and was ready to rise up and
unified revolution.
The reality was that Ireland was heavily divided religiously and politically and
they suppose it unified revolution was not guaranteed.
It would have to overcome this obstacle even if the society of United Irishmen
and wanted it.
The French agree to support him and in 1796 of force of 15,000 soldiers but sent
to Ireland under General Azhar Hoish,
this force alone outnumbered the British presence on Ireland and combined with
the Irish forces had an alarming potential to drive Britain out of Ireland.
It could have even set the stage for a French invasion of Britain and from
there,
no one knows what could have happened and we never will.
As the expedition failed bad December,
weather had prevented the French from lending and Wolfe tone devastated said
that the British had had their greatest luck since the Spanish armada.
When the British responded to the incident,
they cracked down on the Irish.
Hard houses were burned,
people were captured,
killed and tortured.
Intention began to build further rebellion began in May of 1798 in June,
much of Northern Ireland rose up and took control of much of the area,
but the forces there were overwhelmed by British and loyalists.
Forces.
Atrocities were committed on both sides.
Rape and murder of civilians was common among the British and loyalist army,
but the rebels committed their fair share of murder.
Two in one incident locking a number of Protestant civilians and a barn and
lighting it on fire.
On August 22nd French troops finally arrived,
but it was a much smaller force of around a thousand men.
This would not be enough to break the British offensive.
And by October,
the rebellion was defeated and Wolfe tone was captured while the board
friendship rather than face public hanging,
he cut his own throat.
These incidents beginning with calls for a form to outright bloody rebellion
would lead the Irish in the opposite direction of what they were trying to
attain.
The British having struggled with Ireland for over 500 years up to this point
now tried to bring about a final solution to Ireland.
The Irish would lose much of their voice all together in a force.
In joining with Britain in the acts of union in 1801 Ireland's parliament was
dissolved and it came under the direct rural of the parliament in Westminster
with a nations of Britain and Ireland effectively legally joined the Catholic
majority of our land was no longer as much of an issue as the country now,
including Britain,
wasn't majority Protestant nation on the whole with Napoleon,
me getting a set of sites on the whole of Europe,
Britain furthermore could not risk another Irish incident and had to subjugate
the island further Ireland.
Now a full fledged member of the United Kingdom would experience a number of
political and economic benefits though as usual,
mostly favoring the Protestant elite.
The political perspective of much of the Catholic populous remained mostly
unchanged,
especially one once more.
The government had promised to deliver certain rights to the Catholics,
but then with great influence from King George,
the third one on it,
magick varland remained impoverished and underdeveloped and there was still talk
of resistance and rebellion.
Another rebellion was attempted under an Irishman exiled in France,
however,
named Robert Emmet Emmet designed new weapons,
trained a group of soldiers and made detailed plans regarding his rebellion,
which would begin by taking Dublin Castle.
Unfortunately for him,
when his rebellion took place in 1803 it amounted to less than a city riots.
Less than 100 people were killed on both sides,
and Emmett was later captured and executed.
So his rebellion is a footnote among the many rebellions in Ireland.
He's remembered more so for his words prior to his execution.
Let no man right my epitaph first,
no men who knows my motives there now vindicate them,
let not prejudice or ignorance disperse them,
let them and to me,
rest and obscurity and peace and my tomb remain uninstall,
cried,
and my memory in oblivion.
Until other times and other men can do justice to my character.
When my country takes your place among the nations of the earth then and not
till then led to my epitaph be written,
I have done Ireland continued in a similar state as it had for the past century.
Protestants held the power of the country and the Catholics remained a
subjugated.
People prod us at land ownership,
especially from absentee landlords and a lack of agricultural development meant
that farming was a mess for the lower orders in Ireland and poor yields
resulting and feminine and deaths were common between 1816 and 1842 there were
16 incidents of minor to major famines in Ireland,
including one in 1816 often regarded as the year of no summer.
A volcanic eruption in Indonesia caused the dust and debris to block out the
sun.
Snow fell in June and July and crop yields reduced sharply.
Arland relying on subsistence farming suffered considerably.
As you've seen.
These were not the first famines in Ireland,
nor would they be the last.
These issues were exacerbated by taxation.
The most angering of all taxes,
where those placed on Catholics to support the Protestant church.
The amount of poverty and unrest led to an increase in violence and crime.
Rural Ireland was a dangerous and to mulch was place.
Not only were the Irish suffering,
but they were angered by what they felt was a lack of means to do much about
their situation.
In 1823 are wealthy Catholic named Daniel O'connell began to make efforts to try
to change the situation in Ireland.
He believed that much of Ireland's difficulties were rooted in the fact that
Catholics remained second class citizens and he felt that rallying their voice
would have a positive impact on the country.
He founded the Catholic Association,
a group of Catholics dedicated toward his ideas,
which for the cost of only one penny a month attracted the peasantry who were
hit hardest by the situation.
Within five years,
O'connell would make the bold move to run for parliament,
the first Catholic to do so.
Since the 16 hundreds he won the election and the British had to decide what to
do.
Prime Minister Arthur Wellesley,
hero of the Napoleonic wars and born in Dublin himself agreed to accept us
allowing Irish Catholics of vote and enter parliament.
Though of course under the conditions that this would be a very small portion of
the Catholic population reserved for the wealthy minority.
Once in parliament,
O'connell was spent his career trying to reverse the acts of union.
He was not a complete rebel and did not seek independence for Ireland,
but he did want to see Ireland have more self rule and work to bring back its
parliament for Ireland to truly prosper.
He believes it couldn't be entirely ruled by London.
He wouldn't succeed in his efforts towards homeroom,
but through his rallies and protests,
which he strongly believed should be carried out peacefully,
he would be a powerful forest in rallying the Irish voice wants more is peaceful
nature would be instrumental in reversing the Protestant perspective that the
Irish Catholics were a wild rebel and ease the fears of the ulcer.
Protestants that this would need to trouble and insurrection.
Though,
as these movements went on,
as I had throughout much of Irish history,
Ireland was beginning to face a new threat from a new invader across Europe.
A potato blight was moving westward,
affecting millions in Belgium,
Denmark,
France,
Germany,
and the UK.
But when it came to Ireland in 1845 it would hit hardest of all.
Ireland was experiencing a population boom.
It was now home to about 8 million people and it had achieved these numbers
without all the agricultural advancements of the industrial revolution to be
found and the rest of Britain and for the more with a great reliance on a single
crop,
the potato and only a single kind of potato,
which was now under threat when the great portion of this crop throughout the
country became slowly annetable this feminine among all the others in Irish
history around the name on Gordon Moore,
the great death,
none more commonly in English as the Irish potato famine,
the potato blight caused by field Toyota in face,
Don's would cause up to 2 million people to either die or leave Ireland.
The British government had a limited response at first grain and corn shipments
were sent to Ireland and the government employed the impoverished and harsh
labor to be able to afford food.
But in 1846 when the feminine truly started taking a toll,
John Russell became prime minister.
He enacted a laissez faire economic policy and stop the shipments believing that
it wasn't an issue for which the government should be responsible.
There was a mix of response among the British landlords.
Some would go bankrupt in efforts to try to help the Irish poor,
but many absentee would simply evict the impoverished workers and continue to
ship other sources of food out of Ireland in the face of people starving and
dying in the streets.
One of the main government officials involved in colonial efforts,
Charles Trevelyan openly claimed that the famine was a lesson from God.
It was a punishment on Catholics and it was necessary to teach them to be less
reliant on the government.
This event remains one of the most controversial and the history of British and
Irish relations to this day.
As some continued to argue that the Irish were primarily responsible for their
own feminine.
Others argue that the English were guilty of genocide or something close to it
and others argued that no one side was to blame and that both sides made
mistakes in an almost unstoppable event.
1847 is remembered as the black year of the famine.
400,000 people died in black,
47 alone.
Many died from diseases caused by weakness before starvation could kill them a
year later.
The drastic effects of this would encourage the failed 1848 rebellion.
Many of those who could left Ireland.
Immigration from Ireland had been common in the 19th century,
but the famine would greatly intensified these numbers as Irish crowded on boats
and unsanitary and dangerous ships to brave the voyage to places of opportunity
such as nearby Britain,
Canada,
Australia,
and the United States.
Some would later return to Ireland,
but the great majority would go on living and these new countries and before
long that ascendance of Irish emigrants would greatly outnumber the population
of Ireland itself in America.
They would form large communities and cities like Boston and New York,
but what also move westward and the country's great expansion with the
conditions from which the Irish came and the ones in which they found themselves
and their new homelands,
they faced heavy discrimination within a generation of assimilation.
However,
much of this discrimination and stigma largely disappeared and the Irish became
an integral part of the societies to which they immigrated.
At the end of the feminine.
In 1850 a quarter of the Irish population had died or emigrated,
equaling about a million dead and a million who left.
Many would continue to emigrate even after the famine.
Many who left outside of Ulster.
We're among Ireland's more skilled and educated,
which would damage our society further.
Those who stayed bitterly resented the British and the more peaceful movements
under men like Daniel O'connell slowly faded to more violent ones.
This rebellious sentiment.
However,
we coalesce into a greater movement among the emigrants abroad and many Irish
separatist groups were rooted in the United States,
such as the colon of Gayle and the Irish Republican brotherhood known also as a
Finian's in 1858 for decades after the and among the Irish would be mostly
focused on reform resistance and revenge at home and abroad.
In 1867 to Finian's attempted a rebellion in Ireland in the late sixties and
early seventies the Finian's and America,
many of whom were civil war veterans,
staged raids on the Canadian border,
which can is skirmishes intended to cause many Irish Canadians to rise up and
put pressure on the British government to lessen their grip on Ireland.
But such rates failed.
The American government condemn the raids,
but interestingly may have turned a blind eye to them because of Canadian and
British uncertainty on a side in the American civil war.
The Irish Republican brotherhood would nevertheless continue in its resistance
to British domination of the island,
oftentimes resorting to the first acts of Irish terrorism.
In 1878 the potato blight returned to Ireland sparking.
What does remembered as a land war crops failed and impoverished laborers were
once more evicted from their homes.
The economy suffered and the threat of a return of the great feminine concerned
the Irish greatly unrest brood.
And in response to this,
the Irish national land league arose under Michael Debit,
a former fenian demanding rights for the tenant farmers.
The league's primary goals are summarized as the three F's,
fair rent,
fixity of tenure and freedom of sale.
They want it to avoid outrageously high rent from absentee English landlords
wanting to avoid eviction by agreeing to a length of time in which they stayed
on their land and the right to be involved in the sale of the land.
Essentially,
they wanted to bring more power to the tenant farmers from the absentee
landlords and to reverse the most negative effects of English rule over lands,
which they felt were unjustly stolen from their ancestors.
What are the most effective means of resistance was to avoid business and
socialization with landlords and those who did business with them who were
corrupt or unfair to the Irish people.
One of the first to suffer from this practice in Ireland was captain Charles
Cunningham boycott after whom the act was named and spread across the English
language.
British Prime Minister William Gladstone continued his work to try to return the
land to the Irish failing to have done so at this point could have resulted in
major insurrection.
Yet again,
such movements in Ireland would not end here.
However,
in 1875 Charles Stewart par no was elected into parliament.
He would work with glass and on an even bigger change the move toward Irish home
rule,
not independence,
but in Irish parliament and greater autonomy.
Later in his career,
he would make alliances with the Finian's and the Irish Land League,
which was obviously concerning to the English.
In 1886 a home rural bill was introduced to parliament,
but it was turned down fearing it because a breakup of the entire empire.
If Ireland,
Britain's neighbor could resist,
then what have more troublesome places like South Africa or India.
Following this Gladstone's party lost power in Parnell was greatly embarrassed
in the discovery of an ongoing sex scandal with a married woman.
He died in 1891 at the age of 45 from pneumonia.
This movement itself had largely fallen apart,
but the spirit of it had not.
And it coincided with a returned interests in Irish nationalism and Irish
identity.
The Irish people challenge the culture which they felt was becoming worryingly
foreign in an effort to save their own from extinction.
Old Customs culture history and the revival of the language returned in this age
with the question of home rule on the table.
Organizations like con run a gala dedicated to preserving the Irish language
were founded.
Many great figures like Oscar Wilde and William Butler.
Yeats lived in his time home rule was enticing to Ireland except of course,
and Ulster where the inheritance,
namely the Protestant church and the Orange Order requite openly against it,
much of their position rested in union with the British.
They weren't interested in separatism with a nation which might not benefit them
as much.
Many unionists met in Belfast,
work against Irish home rule.
The government made attempts to push the questions decide by appeasing the
rabble with the land purchase act of 1903 but it did not work.
To that end.
By 1912 the question of Irish home rule was back on the table in parliament.
It was approved and was set to take effect.
In September of 1914 Britain had to take a measure to secure rule over Ireland
and granted the country its own parliament again,
but still not everyone was satisfied.
Nearly 500,000 unionist sign the Ulster Covenant on September 28th of that year,
swearing to use any means necessary to prevent home rule.
The first man to his sign was Sir Edward Henry Carson the following year,
a militia known as the Ulster Volunteer Force was organized with 100,000 men
prepared to go to war.
It could offend their place in the British empire even if it were London who
delivered home rule to the Irish.
Irish nationalists formed the Irish volunteers and the Irish citizen army as a
response.
The island's seemed on the brink of civil war.
This civil war may very well have come if not for external problems.
In 1914 world war one broke out dragging the British empire along with Ireland
into war with Germany,
Austria,
and the Ottoman Empire.
The British needing to focus all of their attention on Germany suspended the
home rule bill until the end of the conflict.
While they would have liked to have frozen Ireland for the duration of the
conflict,
it didn't quite work out that way.
The Irish had mixed views on their participation in the war.
Ulster loyal to the British empire,
fully participated.
Many Irish nationalists agreed that Germany was as much of a threat to them as
it was to Britain.
Though a minority of nationalists firmly disagreed and would have rather just
formed a defensive force left out of the war until absolutely necessary.
200,000 Irish men would fight in the first world war and 30,000 with die serving
in the British army while another 20,000 fighting and other armies such as the
American one would perish as well.
In the first day of the battle of the Somme.
Over 5,000 men from the 36th olster division were killed,
one 10th or one six depending on how you look at it,
of all Irishmen killed in the war in a single day with many Irish fighting
abroad.
However,
the ones back home would take advantage of the opportunity that came with
Britain.
Being distracted or revolution would begin in Ireland,
not the bloodiest in Irish history,
but perhaps the most important
urgent with Britain,
distracted by the war.
Radical Irish nationalists felt it was their time to move.
They began plotting rebellion,
even attempting to gain help from the Germans.
Though a shipment of German rifles was prevented by the British navy.
On April 24th,
1916 Easter Monday,
a group of Irish radicals took control of key public buildings in Dublin and
declare the formation of the independent Irish Republic.
They flew the Irish tricolor created in 1848 and modeled off the flag of the
French republic.
The white in the middle of the green and orange symbolize the hopes of a
unification between Catholics and Protestants.
The British were caught off guard,
but when they responded,
they did so brutally.
485 were killed on both sides.
Thousands were wounded and much of central Dublin was a steroid and a fighting.
The leaders of the rebellion,
ricotta and executed not many Irishmen had immediately risen up to take part in
the revolution.
But when Britain and their eyes excessively punished Ireland for the uprising by
putting a country under martial law and imprisoning many innocent people,
it sparked a greater revolutionary sentiment.
The leading Irish political party Shin Feign,
which was incorrectly blamed for the uprising,
took advantage of the situation and created its own parliament called doll Erin
rejecting British rule.
It created the Irish Republican Army to defend its cause.
When the British began conscription in Ireland matters became worse.
And when World War One ended,
things began to pick up.
A few months later on the 21st of January,
1919 the Irish war of independence had begun.
Leading the movement was Ayman de Valera,
Arthur Griffiths and the military commander,
Michael Collins.
The British would later reinforce the Royal Irish constabulary with a force
known as the black and tans.
After the color of the uniforms.
They were largely veterans of the first World War and they would ruthlessly
pursue the Irish Republican Army.
Now fighting a guerrilla war against the British,
including targeting civilians,
but the black and tans or in a special reputation for it,
rape,
murder,
torture,
and the burning of entire villages were common.
They killed priests and politicians.
One famous incident was the killing of Thomas McCurtain,
the Lord Mayor of Cork,
and a longtime rebel who was killed and his home in front of his wife.
One of the most famous incidents of the overall war,
however,
was bloody Sunday.
On November 21st Michael Collins ordered the killing of a number of top British
army officer is and intelligence network officials.
11 were killed,
three were wounded.
The black and tans responded by killing three Irish soldiers.
They were holding prisoner and opening fire on a crowd of civilians at a
football match.
That year.
The British government gave Northern Ireland in Belfast home rule,
though the divides between the north and south were rooted in history.
Hundreds of years old.
This was the beginning of the divide between the modern nation of Ireland and
Northern Ireland,
which to this day remains in the United Kingdom.
Southern Ireland continued.
It's fighting,
but many on both sides would be eager to end the conflict.
By the following year,
peace talks began in October of 1921 with Michael Collins and Arthur Griffith
attending but not and the Valera to the disappointment of the Irish.
The situation of Northern Ireland was not up for debate.
Six of the 32 Irish counties would remain in the UK.
However,
the two sides agreed to the formation of the Irish Free State.
This was not a 100% independent nation,
but it did function fairly independently in a similar way as Canada.
At the same time,
in 1921 the British had ruled Ireland for 754 years.
Collins believed that this agreement was the first step to creating a truly free
Irish nation,
that it's people had sought all that time,
but others back home like de Valera disagreed.
He believed and nothing less than total independence.
In January of 1922 the doll put the treaty with Britain to a vote.
64 members were in favor.
57 we're against bill losing half did not accept its situation peacefully.
And by June as civil war broke out with Collins on one end and de Valera on the
other,
in August of that year,
Griffith died of a heart attack and Michael Collins was killed in an ambush.
Nevertheless,
in 1923 due to British help,
the civil war was over what the Free State of victory and de Valera surrendered
and all 3000 people had died in the fighting of both wars to the Irish.
The men and women who had died had made the ultimate sacrifice for a nation,
which now had a new future.
Both the Irish and Northern Irish resenting each other for the positions they
had taken,
but many were glad to be separated from each other.
And on their way toward a new future,
which they hoped would be free from the fear that the other would take over.
Ireland and Northern Ireland began to adapt the new ways of doing things
politically,
economically,
socially,
culturally,
legally,
militarily,
et cetera.
In a rather complicated time.
Fascism and communism were on the rise and it looked as the war was brewing in
Europe,
yet again,
it did,
and when Britain became involved in what would become the second world war
against Germany,
though Churchill and Roosevelt encouraged Irish involvement,
the Irish remained neutral.
The leader of the government at the time was de Valera,
who clearly was pardoned for that whole rebellion,
saying a decade earlier and felt that the nation was not in the right situation
to be involved in such a major war,
nor was it exactly in his eyes a war in which the Irish had to be involved
naturally though,
and the Irish government favor of the British,
they were affected by British losses,
and thousands of volunteers joined the British fight while hundreds of thousands
of others worked in British jobs,
Northern Ireland.
However,
as a part of the United Kingdom join the fight fully and was even bombed by the
German air force multiple times for its strategic naval importance during such
bombings,
firefighters from the south often helped the northerners recover and they would
even detain German pilots.
When the war was over,
the allies still somewhat frowned on.
The Irish neutrality.
Churchill even refer to the Valera as useless and the Soviet Union argued
against their admission to the United Nations claiming that the Irish were
fascist sympathizers.
I encourage you to decide for yourself whether you think Arlin should have done
more or whether they were justified in sitting one out.
In 1949 the Irish Free State became a fully independent republic.
Though finally independent.
That desire for unification between Ireland and Northern Ireland never truly
disappeared.
Even as a two countries set off further and our separate ways and began to
modernize.
Unfortunately for the island,
it would not be so simple as going separate ways.
As a significant Catholic minority remained in Northern Ireland,
Protestants and Catholics remained segregated.
Catholics often felt that they were still second class citizens in regard to
employment,
education,
and living economic difficulties in Northern Ireland worried the Protestant
community of foreign threats,
namely of an Irish nationalists takeover.
In 1968 [inaudible],
the Northern Ireland Civil Rights Association was founded with the interest of
guaranteeing Catholics the same rights and opportunities as Protestants,
though things would not go down so well that decade,
these differences would lead to a conflict in Northern Ireland,
known as the troubles between Irish Para military organizations,
Ulster loyalist paramilitaries,
and the British army.
It would quickly evolve into a political and ethnic conflict rather than an
actual debate of Catholicism and Protestantism with the olster loyalist
offending,
what they saw as their union with Britain and the Irish attacking what they saw
as an age old incursion on their island protestors clashed on the streets.
When the situation became out of control,
the British military was sent into the area.
In 1969 civilians,
police and soldiers were killed and outbreaks of violence.
The Irish Republican Army arose again pledging to fight for the rights of
Catholics in the area.
Many men and women fearing that the British government had taken aside of the
Northern Irish or at least fail to protect them,
began to support them.
The IRA began a campaign of terrorism and guerrilla warfare and the region
bombing specific targets of national and economic importance to the Northern
Irish and 1972 Northern Ireland was once again put on a direct rule from London
as the situation fail to resolve.
The Provisional IRA continued the war now aiming indeed to unite Arland and
expelled the British,
the unionist paramilitaries acted and what they saw as self defense and the
British government acted mainly to secure the area and and the violence.
In 1974 the IRA bomb the number of soldiers in Scotland.
In 1976 the British ambassador to Ireland was killed.
In 1979 the queen's cousin,
the Earl of mountain baton of Burma was killed in 1984 Margaret Thatcher was
targeted but survived throughout the nineties many areas of London were
attacked.
By 1989 almost 3000 people of all walks of life had been killed in the fighting
and as the conflict extended into the nineties many we're hoping desperately for
a resolution.
By 1994 the British government announced that it had no personal pursuits in
Ireland and sought only to object.
We defend the will of the majority.
Many Irish nationalists laid down their arms.
Peace talks were beginning.
They were even visited by American President,
Bill Clinton,
who is one of many American presidents to have Irish heritage,
peace talks and Iras.
Eyes were taking too long and violence temporarily resumed in London,
but by 1997 the cease fire was back on again under Prime Minister Tony Blair on
Good Friday,
April 10th,
1998 the Belfast Agreement was signed,
though the IRA would not truly announce the end of their armed campaign until
2005 in total,
3,532 people had died and over 47,000 people were injured.
What I do want to be clear about with this is that as I have discussed in many
of my other videos,
this history is alive and well we,
or at least the Irish in this case are not separate from it.
It's not something they just read about in history books or listen to an
incredible fire of learning documentaries.
It's something that they live and this issue dating back to the 16th century or
maybe the 12th century,
depending on how you see it,
is still an issue of a lot of tension,
anger and dispute in the two countries today.
Most of us,
I'm sure lived or were born during this dispute.
Going back to King James the first and Henry the eighth though these conflicts
have not disappeared.
Compare to much of its history.
The past decade or two has been a golden age for the Republic of Ireland.
In the two thousands it's economy was so strong that it was referred to as the
Celtic Tiger and it standards of living became some of the best in Europe.
Culture exploded in Ireland and a number of writers,
musicians,
politicians,
sportsmen,
and artists around today are Irish.
Arland entered a recession in 2008 causing unemployment to reach almost 15%
emigration common in the past return temporarily,
but they have since turned much round and economically Ireland is since 2014
called the Celtic Phoenix.
The Irish language is still struggling,
but it is making a bit of a rebound and in a world where many languages will
unfortunately go extinct in our lifetimes,
Irish may be among the endangered languages to survive.
It is a language which I have already planned to learn myself today.
Ireland struggles with many social issues which are common across the world,
but as always,
Ireland is making up its own mind on these issues and doing things their way.
I hope you've enjoyed this documentary.
My hope is that someone who is unfamiliar with Irish history can just kind of
sit back and spend an hour and a half or so listening to this video and come out
with a general understanding of Irish history in full and to look at the map
differently from now on.
And of course that is my intention with all my videos,
especially my documentaries.
I know that this is the case for many viewers because I know here in the United
States they don't teach Irish history apart from the potato famine and
immigration,
which is unfortunate given how much of our population has Irish heritage today,
about 33 million people or 10% of the American population,
which is interesting compared to modern Ireland's population of just 6.5 million
people.
My intention as always here at fire of learning is not to tell you how to think,
but rather to give you things to think about.
I encourage all of you to decide for yourselves what to think of Irish history,
Northern Ireland,
Britain,
and all the issues involved here.
I do think it is worth pointing out however,
that in Arlene's long history,
whatever has been thrown at them,
famines,
plague,
war with Vikings and centuries long English and British rule.
They have always stood back up and fought,
do things for themselves and to remain who they are as a people if you're
interested.
I have done documentaries on the history of other countries as well as other
subjects like dreams,
coffee,
aliens,
terraforming,
and shorter video is on all kinds of subjects.
I'd invite you to come check those out and to subscribe to keep up with all the
videos I have coming in the future.
Griff Maha.
Good for watching.
Hey,
and yet.